back everybody we're closely following
the Atlanta trial of rapper Young Thug
and his alleged gang young slime life
also known as YSL jury selection is off
to a very slow start as a legal
Contraband continues to be smuggled to
the defendants 14 members of YSL are
being tried together with racketeering
murder and other gang-related charges on
the line for each of them 28 YSL members
were initially indicted with eight
members taking plea deals and sick six
members having their cases severed jury
selection started earlier this month and
was slated to last five to six weeks but
that timeline might mean even longer now
as the court addressed three Contraband
incidents in three days you see someone
smuggled marijuana to one co-defendant
in a pair of shoes another
co-defendant's mother was arrested for
trying to sneak tobacco products and
rolling papers in with a bag of clothes
and most recently a different incident
caused jury selection to Halt for the
entire day on Wednesday check out what
the judge had to say when he addressed
the court all about it
we've had yet another instance of
alleged Contraband
um being introduced to our space and as
a result of that and a subsequent
investigation one of our inmates
unfortunately had to go to Grady
hospitals the other thing I would just
invite Council to talk with their
clients about I know I've mentioned this
three times now what is considered to be
acceptable behavior this is the third
time that we've had Contraband
introduced into this um in in this space
the Court's concern is that this may
pose issues to them remaining and be
pres and being present in this space
Brian how serious is this sneaking items
to inmates unfortunately it happens a
little bit more than it should but
specifically in Georgia it's a felony I
mean you could do one to five years in
jail now when you look at the Statue it
mainly talks about drugs or guns I'm not
sure who's sneaking guns into jails but
also what I've seen a lot is cell phones
if you don't get a lot of cell phone
time in jails or prison people want to
be able to communicate with their loved
ones but there's also this catch-all
that any Contraband that the warden or
superintendent does not allow for an
incarcerated person or someone waiting
uh a sentencing they cannot have and so
these people boy they might not do the
four or five years they're looking at
some serious jail time for trying to
sneak in such Contraband but Terry it's
delaying it right there's just been so
many delays in this trial we haven't
even gotten to the substance of what
this all is about how long do you think
it's going to actually take to try the
case oh I think it's going to take quite
a while they estimated it was going to
be six to nine months it's had such a
slow start it's going to be 9 to 12 if
not more they started out with 56 pages
in this count as far as the you know
indictment was concerned and they had
multiple 27 defendants and as you
mentioned some of them have pled out
some of them have had their cases
separated and so I think it's going to
be a very long trial and don't forget
it's a RICO charge that's not an easy
charge for the prosecution to Prevail
they have to show that there's an
Enterprise and that there was
investments in that Enterprise and that
it was maintained and with all of these
defendants you're going to have multiple
witnesses to show that each and every
one was contributing to that Enterprise
so I don't think that they're going to
even finish picking a jury as far as
this is concerned for weeks and weeks
and you know the opening statements just
imagine each and every defendant having
their own individual attorney is going
to do an opening statement because
they're going to have different
interests so I definitely think it's
going to take quite some time and you
may lose yours I was going to say that
good luck to the jury being able to stay
on such a long trial Brian Terry thanks
so much everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America